oh
good afternoon fellow councillors
members of the public
council
please remain upstanding for the council
of prayer
almighty god grant to us all needed
guidance wisdom and judgment
as we face the past before us
and enable us now and always worthily
to discharge the sacred transplaced by
the people in our hands
thank you apologies
has
put in an apology as a um
proactive move he may need to withdraw
if a appointee turns up his house so
he's just said he might need to withdraw
and apologizes if that occurs
okay
discussion questions
no members of the public will
thank you
and a major late late item
yes we have a major late item i received
a response from the department of
internal affairs
last night and i would ask that be
considered by council today
move it be accepted
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
against
harry
move on to declaration of
interest there any changes there
no all right
minutes of the meeting of council held
on the
28th of april
2022
uh 26th i think it was your worship oh
26th of april 20
22. i'll move that way your worship
second
you moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
against
carried minutes of the meeting out on
the 26th of april
2022
be confirmed
you've just done yourself
three minutes of the infrastructural
services committee meeting held on may
3rd
yes i will
confirm
move that those minutes be confirmed and
also
recommend to council to adopt
the following
resolutions made there and that's to do
with the reserve land sales and that is
endorsed proceeding
with disposal of 44 herewood road
endorse proceeding with disposal of 231
scott street
endorsed proceeding with disposal of 794
queens drive
endorsed proceeding with disposal of 21
hour bay road
endorsed proceeding with disposal of 114
mokomoko road
i'll second those your worship
along with the
cited recommendations
moved and segmented
discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
against carried
um
now the minutes of
the infrastructural committee held on
the third of may with station never just
done that your worship we are now doing
the minutes of the bluff community board
meeting
held on the 9th of may
i'll move those your worship
i'll second those your worship
moved and seconded discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say i
your
worship the minutes of the bluff
community board meeting held on the
third of may we should have just left no
we've just done that you worship oh i've
done that as well very good
now we're doing this 27
and it's of the extraordinary meeting of
performance policy and partnerships
committee held on the 10th of may
you wish it would move that those
minutes be confirmed
i'll second that
moved and seconded any discussion
questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye
carried
minutes of the extraordinary meeting
held on the 8th of may 2022
uh
your worship i think we're at the
minutes of the extraordinary meeting of
council held on the 10th of may
and i'll move that way your worship
thanks it's moved and seconded no we
don't have a second second that you
worship
thank you
it's moved and seconded
you further discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against kerry
minutes of the performance policy and
partnerships committee meeting held on
the 10th of may 2022
i'll move those minutes be confirmed
your worship uh councillor i wonder if
we could they the council cannot confirm
the minutes of the commission they'd be
received yeah
moved and seconded
any discussion
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against carried
adoption of the road and traffic bylaw
2022 be moved
i'd like to move that they will be taken
separately is that possible
um councillor you've said two things in
that
are you moving the recommendations in
the report and are you requesting that
they be put separately yes
thank you
there any objections to that that
they'll be moved separately
put it to the boat i'm sorry your
worship is there a seconder for them
speaking to for that
counselor
i'll second
no it's understood that they'll be put
separately your worship they will be put
separately
remover and seconder for that taking
them separately
that's not required and the mover did
ask for that when he moved the motion
very good
put it to the boat
so
is that item one you're putting to the
vote that the report be received yes
put it to the vote that the
report be received
that hasn't been put yet so he's just
putting it to the vote now
put it to the vote
hi
against carrie
now can i ask councillor arnold would
you like items
to
a b c d all of those alpha to be put
separately or can we put all of item two
together
um up to number c
compiler
so if i understand a b and c i'm fine
with a b and c you're happy to be put
together
okay
so
you can move items two a b and c
put those as one
yes
okay we can put those as one
remover and seconder for that they've
been moved and seconded
to the vote all on purpose say aye
aye against
go here and against there
oh there we go
so 2d should be put separately
now the number and second are agreeing
with that yes it was requested at the
time you worship do we get to talk to
the motions now from now on if you wish
to
well will i talk now yes certainly
through your worship i'm just
going to vote against any speed change
because we've gone up for public
consultation
and the public clearly said
the majority 60
said they want no change
the reason i voted for the schools
change is because also a clear majority
wanted change in the school so
from here on and i'll be voting now i'll
be voting with what the public said i'd
be more happy if there was something
done whereby there are roads that do
that are of concern if they're sort of
changed as a instead of on a
uh
across the board
change rather i'd rather have them sort
of singled out and changed individually
or have some process where that can be
done as opposed to a sweeping change
overall
we we go out for consultation to listen
to the public and the public clearly
said 60 clearly said they would like no
change in the speed the speed limit at
50 is not a target it's that's the limit
you you can go
so of course if it's conditions
say that you should be going less then
you go less because there's also another
there is a charge called
keyless use
which would could mean that you were
using your vehicle carelessly in a
built-up area with a lot of people
even at less than 50. so i don't see the
need to have signs all around the place
i see the sdc aren't doing any changes
at the stage either and i see confusion
between their district and air district
if we've got changes of speed or um
throughout the similar district and i
see uh the the
the difference in signage all around
town um
also confusing um
at the moment you can
concentrate on your driving
if you're looking signs and you don't
actually sort of you might miss it you
think oh gosh you're wondering what i'm
switching here and i can just see
panic sitting in with some particular
drivers i don't see it helping there are
some changes here that i do agree with
um
but generally speaking across the board
i i'm against i'm i'm
for actually sticking to what the
population wanted of 60 of them wanted
no change
so um that's just my reasons that i'll
be voting against some of these
thank you well i must say you've been
very consistent in your opposition
you've
been voting
against that adoption of well i'm just
voting for what the people that we asked
wanted
so i'm actually not in opposition really
i'm for the what the people wanted
thank you uh two things just point of
order here i i thought we were
discussing each one um item by item
um and that seems to have gone by the
buy because obviously when you look
further down the list here we have
relevant speed changes that were
requested by the actual inhabitants of
the road
so
i'm sure they don't want to be
put aside their requests by a survey
that i think was only 60 odd people and
the percentages were
were taken from that whatever the number
was and i think the people who lebanon
road should have the choice to make that
decision
so are we going to carry on and take
these one by one
or not
that's the question it's indicated but
um i thought that's what we resolved
your worship counselor arnold speak uh
seeking to speak again but actually he
will have the right of reply as the
mover of the motion there is a list of
councillors here that are wishing to
speak
counselor
sorry to kind of see an answer to the
question please sorry your worship are
we taking them one by one
that was requested yep cool
thank you councillor
thank you your worship i just um i
suppose want to ask a point of order as
well
um councillor arnold
indicated he had voted for the schools
but was then asking
um for all the others to be taken singly
but in fact we've voted on sea
which is the central city windsor and
south city streets so i'm a little bit
confused
did councillor arnold
mean to not vote for c which we have
already voted for
can we clarify that point please i can
answer that worship
to comment on that
question
uh your worship i just want to bring
everybody back
this
motion
is that the council note the
recommendation of the infrastructural
services committee to adopt the bylaw
incorporating the following changes
as a result of consultation
i would go further and say to you that
if there is any mood at this table to
not adopt bylaw
we will need to go back to the beginning
again
however on the basis that i think there
are only one or two dissenting from this
what you're currently distributing
is what the infrastructure services
committee has recommended to you
[Music]
thank you worship um
i heard the point that was that was made
by
councillor arnold and i think he also
perhaps incorrectly voted in support of
c uh without realizing that that was for
um areas that now the other b is for
schools
it's great to read
and i understand and
as we went through the
submission hearing process
and had read the the
documents prepared by staff
why there's concern around confusion of
changing speed limits within within an
area
and i was a little uneasy about it at
the time uh but we took a family trip to
christchurch at easter
and moved around there and and within
christchurch city the speed limits
change regularly
and actually it's your obligation as a
driver to pay attention to all signs
um and and if you're doing that and some
of these signs you know the the speed
limits around schools will apply
at certain times
and
the burden is on the driver to live up
to their end of the bargain
i understand that
there's some inconsistency with with our
neighbors but
i guess there might be inconsistency out
of christchurch city as well
ultimately i heard what people were
saying i think particularly the the
recommendations
um
that we had from people in specific
areas are things that we want to be
cognizant of there were some that were
part of previous resource consent
hearings that had um
information that perhaps hadn't been
applied and
to that end i'm supporting the overall
motion which is the recommendation of
infrastructural services committee for
for the entire suite of recommendations
sir thank you
you
well you started the discussion
counselor arnold so you've been [ __ ]
yes councillor super and uh
correct um yeah i didn't mean to vote to
include seeing that actually so um
i guess from here on and i will be
voting
no because
from sea onwards um
except for the situations that councilor
pottinger described where people
actually want that and that's what i'm
saying there will be individual cases
that
there are situations like that that
should change
but generally overall i'm
not for
the changes that are mooted here
in general there is the odd exception
that has to sound like a process whereby
you know that
the council could individually just do
streets from time to time as required
so your worship the motion has been
moved and second to reduce the speed
limit on esk street between d street and
calvin street to 10 kilometers
and there have been speakers to that
motion i think you can put it now
thank you
and now put it to the vote all in favor
say aye aye
do you want your vote recorded
yes please and would you like it
recorded on all of the remaining
well
we'll note
so
2e is to amend the speed limits on the
named rural sea sealed and unsealed
roads
that's been moved and seconded
moved and seconded
in the discussion question
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye against
if most
you'd like your vote against reporters
f is to amend the speed limit on brown
road to 40 kilometers in response to
community feedback
any discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
aye again
don't know that recorded
no counsel
i'm not against him no yeah
um 2g is to amend the speed limit on
aboriginal bay road between t rai road
and 91 alvaro bay road to 40 kilometers
in response to community feedback
discussion questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
uh councillor arnold i wonder if you
would entertain putting h i and j
together
given that they are minor amendments
in terms of existing by law
h i and j yep
yep that's fine so those three
paragraphs can be put together your
worship okay so that's three
in that combo
any further discussion questions
you can put that to the vote you worship
thank you i'll put it to the vote then
all in favor say aye aye
against
harry
number three in that suite is to resolve
to adopt a speed limit of 50 kilometers
to be implemented for tape hillary
subdivision when the development is
vested as road
it's been moved and seconded
we've been seated at any discussion
questions
answer patterns um my question is that
and i'm pretty sure that
i'm right but it's no harm in checking
that this is an urban subdivision as
would be rosedale or waverly or
something like that and
it would then be treated with the same
speed limits that those current
subdivisions are treated with
correct right thank you now that's good
move now um no you worship you need to
put that motion
okay i'll put that motion all in favor
say i i against
carried
number four is resolved to adopt a speed
limit of 50k to be implemented for
inverurie subdivision when future
development is vested as road with
council
put it to the vote
all in
number five
is note that waka kotahi has approved
the three variable speed limits on rural
roads which was required prior to
adoption of these news feeds under
section 4.42 c of the waka kotahi 2017
setting of speed limit rules
thank you any discussion or questions
put it to the vote all in favor say aye
against
and if we could have a drum roll item
number six is to adopt the roading and
rapid bylaw
okay
any questions discussion
put it to the boat all in favor say aye
aye against carriage
indeed celebration is worthy after the
consultation that's taken place to get
that
through
very good
now we are up to item 12 which is the
adoption of the stormwater by law 2022.
now that is that to be taken
i would move that both that this council
receives the report
and also
note the resolutions of the
infrastructure services committee and
deliberating on the stormwater by law
third may
2022 to recommend to council the
following
through
following recommendations through the
four
i'm happy to stick in that
thank you it's moved and
discussion
questions
put it to the vote
all in favor say aye aye against carrie
[Music]
so we'll do that now
yes we've going backwards for a little
while back up the truck
got major late items that
we've accepted
and now we can discuss it thank you your
worship this
letter from the dia comes in response to
the
legacy report that you considered at
your last meeting
and agreed that i should write to the
dia
and seek their feedback
uh i think there's nothing more i need
to say
counseling
counselor
thank you worship that was the award for
the most
ungraceful unmasking of the meeting um
this is the
i guess the final part of the process
that we've gone through with
working on working together and
was triggered of course by the initial
letter of concern from dia
resulted in council putting together a
plan has resulted in the
appointment and support of the two eas
and um
a lot of uncomfortable naval gazing that
we've gone
through over the past
couple of years
the key part of the letter from mr ward
from from dia
is really the the final paragraph they
acknowledge
a lot of the process that we've gone on
but they've also offered
the congratulations to council for
for achieving the outcomes we set to in
a short time frame
and at a lower than expected cost to to
what would budgeted for ratepayers which
i think we
everybody would be grateful for uh
that said let's not lose sight of the
fact that it has come at a cost
and and was one at the start of the term
we probably hadn't budgeted on
but i guess the ultimate compliment is
in the the final comment from mr ward
where he points out that council's
efforts will serve as a roadmap for
other councils
who find themselves in a similar
situation of dealing with dysfunction
and and conflict and i think that's
probably
um
the greatest compliment that
we can receive all things considered
the letter refers to trust issues with
with ratepayers i think
all
facets of local government are
challenged
in that area
um it's kind of like used car sales
people in some senses that
for some reason there's just
an element of suspicion despite the fact
you could actually be selling somebody a
really good car
um
but we've gone through it uh
i i i'm not sure what else we could do
apart from continue to
deliver decisions with confidence and
and transparency not just to the end of
this term but but overcoming terms and
that trust is something that
is going to not only be our
responsibility but the responsibility of
of the following councils
not singular
um
i'd like to move that we receive the
letter
and that we also
acknowledge the work um
of jeff and lindsay as our eas through
this process
uh
they come at governance with different
skill sets
and backgrounds and i think that has
served council in in a very
useful way um
both have
extensive experience and and great
credentials and have been
um
very reasoned very reliable and and a
pleasure to deal with and and
approachable
um when looking for
either guidance support
or or just um a knowing nod sometimes
that things are going well
um so
my motion sarah is that we receive the
letter and we offer a vote of thanks
to the external
advisors for their work with us over the
past 18 months happy to second that your
worship and to endorse the comments
yes well i've been endorsed the comments
too and that
i think if you get
any group of new zealanders
representing a wide cross section of
their local
boundaries
they
you're going to have friction it's just
part of the democratic process
and i'm
surprised that the letter wasn't harsher
than
uh as outlined
the
it's just the process that we have to go
under
every three years
and
they um
i think
have done a good job
with the
situation as it was
and i think i take a very positive view
of
issues like this
i think
they'll resolve themselves
over time
and
we'll look back on this as a golden era
and um
all right you can
put
try and
put the blame onto
one or two individuals including myself
but
and i take responsibility for
for my share of the
mishaps
that
if you compare us to other councils
like tower rover
we haven't done too bad
get the questions
[Applause]
all right i'll put it to the vote then
all in favor of receiving the report i'm
thinking that's responsible for drawing
that up
all in favor say aye
aye against
gary
there is no
other urgent business number
thank you there being no other urgent
business i mean that we go into public
excluded session
i think the members of the public have
taken a time out from their busy lives
to
take part in their democratic processes
which is so important in this country
your worship i'll second that with the
exception of mr grant and mr mckenzie
to remain
well i didn't quite put the full motion
so we can just
accept it as i don't have to go through
the formality of it being
a um
an amendment
that's all right we've
taken
alteration
and thank them as well for their efforts
i'm sure they've helped
educate us a lot of time
on
good procedure
well i'm praying to say hi
hi
your worship
to logan as the member of the media and
to anybody on live stream the amount
you